hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
seventh
thousand and twenty three
what's going on how why yeah
um oh my God it's the last [__]
Monday of February what are you gonna do
with it
oh that means I go back into the [__]
my 10-day
you know detox oh Bill are you gonna
bring this up every month all right I
won't but I'll tell you what I'm I'm
dropping weight
I'm finally losing this [__] coveted
[__] that I've been walking around with
and according to studies even if you
walk around with just an extra five
pounds on your belly just that extra
five pounds the amount of extra stress
it puts on on your heart
will stop you
from getting to be bitched at by your
wife for another eight years
you know you'll miss all of that
um you'll miss your shuffling years
I like how people think if they're
hastening their desk they're going to
miss their shuffling years it's like
only if you drop dead only if you're
lucky enough to drop dead
underrated dropping dead
no suffering for you just for everyone
around you
all right
and then I guess the nicer death to
[__] go through a disease and then
everybody gets to say goodbye
is dropping dead the Irish goodbye of
the ultimate Irish goodbye
[Laughter]
sorry I am in a [__] uh
I don't know it's been raining the last
couple of days and then last night I was
down The Comedy Store doing the great
Josh Adam Maya's show the goddamn Comedy
Jam
and um I told him like a month ago I
told him I would do the show and I
forgot I said that and then he's like
hits me up he's like he's like yeah what
song do you want to do
and I was like I don't know I don't want
to do any more from my [__] metal 80s
days let's get into the 90s so I go you
want to play a Nirvana song and he goes
all right Smells Like Teen Spirit yeah
that always kills
um and then like three four days before
the jam
he goes dude if we did Black Hole Sun
right before
Smells Like Teen Spirit that would
[__] kill
and I'm thinking like yeah it absolutely
would but that's not an easy song
I'm a father of two I'm a I'm a [__]
Guitar Center dad drummer I can't put
that [__] together
right
I I got all into my feels I got all this
scared
I started catastrophizing I was just
like all right [__] it I'll I'll
figure it out we Winged It bit of a
train wreck in the end but uh the part
in the middle that's in nine banana
Bell thick no seven eight nine banana do
in my life whatever the words are in
dispose I'm always like so locked into
listening to whatever the band is doing
I never really listened to the lyrics
until it gets to the chorus you know
except for row row row your boat I mean
it's kind of had a hard to miss those
but all the other songs
so
we did that song
and uh
and then we did smell like team spirit
it was so much fun I must have made like
[__] 20 mistakes in both songs
um Smells Like Teen Spirit of course
Dave Grohl not an easy [__] song
you think it's easy baby
he just does all this weird [__] boom
boom bad look at that and he goes good
taco good Deco he does like a flam on
his snare
and on the floor tom but in between both
he goes over and hits the hi-hat you
know because why make it easy
um you know what it is is he's repeating
a theme that he that he created in the
beginning of the song huh who's watched
a couple of drum videos I have do I know
what creating a theme means uh no
means I remember you did something like
that earlier that's what a theme is and
then it makes people in the crowd like
me go yay right
and then you buy the single
I'll tell you I had mixed emotions doing
um
not sound garden more Nirvana I had
mixed emotions because that band
I've always had like a love hate thing
where obviously it's fantastic music but
I hated that band because they I've said
this amount they they and that band
ended my youth
all right I turned 23 there's no more
fun birthdays after that right
you got to wait until you oh somebody
said last night you get to rent a car at
like 25.
um
but come on I mean that doesn't compare
to you know getting able to vote no
um being able to drink legally
going to a titty bar and participate in
human trafficking
right well now I'm supposed to get
excited because I can rent a [__]
Ford Festiva
um did they call it the Festiva because
they moved their plant to Mexico is
Festiva a Latin word
is it a Mediterranean like is it a love
language word
is it just something some guy in his
suit came up with in Pontiac Michigan I
don't know
um
anyway yeah I was 23 years old so
basically my youth was over like the
next exciting thing that happens to you
on a birthday is when you turn 50 and
you get an AARP Cod
and you walk into the movies and they go
that'll be 92.50 and you were like
not so fast youngster and they go we're
sorry it'll be 89.95 you know I've never
used that [__] thing
I tried using it at the movies one time
I mean I think it's so great that when
you get old they give you a discount on
stuff
they know it's like all right we gotta
this guy needs you know
this guy needs to be cut a break he's
old he knows he's gonna [__] you know
kick the bucket soon let's let's hook
him up
with that you know little discount on
the new George Clooney Julia Roberts
rom-com
anti-rom-com they're divorced they don't
like each other right and I can go in
there and rather than pay whatever a
movie ticket costs now
are you that out of touch Bill no I just
use my credit card and I don't even pay
attention
I literally just give the thing to him
and then they give me what I wanted to
buy back and then you know they're like
do you want a receipt and I always say
no I don't they go okay
and then I walk away and I have no idea
how much things cost
like you remember when um
George Herbert Walker
was running for president and they asked
him how much a dozen eggs cost and he
didn't know and they got all over him
what he should have said is oh yeah
what's the bank angle you want to be at
when you're trying to get a [__] zero off
your [__] tail so you don't [__]
die when you're 18.
let me tell you something lady you can
buy those eggs because of what I did
do you know um
Chino Airport out here has it has an
aviation museum and they have the only
um
I think only in in captivity uh Japanese
zero like all you know not shot up or
anything like that over here
and uh
the only one that we have I gotta go
check that out I mean that's legendary I
was reading about those dog fights and
the Japanese zero was way lighter and
way faster
ours was heavier and slower but you were
much more protected where um
I feel like the Japanese Pilots were in
like a race car
where I don't know if you ever got an
opportunity to walk up to a race car it
looks like the biggest piece of [__]
you've ever seen in your life it's
literally an engine a roll cage and a
seat that's it steering wheel and then
they just put like it's like kind of
particle board for the uh the body of
the car
um
anyway what the [__] am I talking about
I was trying to talk about Nirvana I'm
talking about World War II Aviation
which I know nothing about I read
Flyboys that's it it told the stories of
Pilots
it didn't talk about the aircraft
um
so anyway
yeah that that uh I would turn 23 and
that album came out in [__] overnight
overnight MTV and everybody was just
like this is the new [__] sound and I
can't I don't I've never seen anything
like that in my life
as far as just overnight it was like
this shit's over and this [__] is in now
because I even feel like once grunge
died down well grunge didn't really have
a long run at all it was kind of like
from [__] 91 to about 95
96 Maybe
then Eminem and all those guys came in
right and then I wanted that way tell me
why I know [__] something's heartache
whatever the boy bands came in
um
and overlap and all of that was Wu-Tang
Biggie Tupac right
Coolio
I remember some stuff
I was doing so many stand-up spots that
Whole Decade is a blur
but I I never seen
such an abrupt
like
literally just [__] cut the head off
the snake heavy metal is done this [__]
is in overnight
overnight people that were going to the
MTV and music awards for 10 years in a
row did not get an invite
then there was that one sort of like
caught in the middle thing which would
be the the skid row great album
the Slave to the Grind album the
follow-up
to their debut album
am I hosting a show on [__] serious
XM right now I feel like I am
that is a great album and I feel like it
got lost in the [__] Shuffle of all
that music coming out so it took me a
good four years to finally admit that
Nirvana was a really [__] great band
and that I love their music
um so anyway last night
went to God damn Comedy Jam
[Music]
um
we did both of those songs and you know
like I said I [__] up a bunch of times
but I had a good time I finally got over
the whole like I have to play this
exactly the way that other person I
gotta go get the I gotta I gotta go
watch people do drum covers and I don't
know it's just like you know [__] this
all right let me just
do my version of it and I'll just have a
good time and um it was fun I wasn't
nervous at all I don't get nervous
playing drums and
in front of people anymore which is
pretty cool I remember back in the day I
would get so nervous I felt like I
couldn't even feel my legs
then I was just trying to get through it
and I'd be thinking like towards oh my
God it's almost over these innocent okay
it's over all right it's over I did it
oh but I forgot to enjoy it
um
anyway and then I was sort of fighting
off a depression when I was down the
comedy store which has happened to me
lately because just you want to talk
about like a [__]
a change oh my God look at this look at
this a [__] a Segway here like from
hair metal to grunge I would say
pre-print pandemic Comedy Store to post
pandemic Comedy Store the amount of
people
that were there and are now not moved
away
you know got canceled or whatever the
[__] happened and I'm down there and now
I think I'm the oldest guy down there
now
like oh my God
what happened where just out of
curiosity where is everybody
is kind of what I thought and then a
buddy of mine came in
and I was like oh God thank God a
familiar face and he told me
he just closed on a house
you know like 10 states away and you
know because he can't afford a house out
here which I totally understand and I'm
just like
[__]
um
so
so that's happening
it just sort of uh
I don't know sort of [__] addressed
it in my head I was like all right
how do you do this I you know I just
started thinking if I just started
thinking about George Carlin
it was George Carlin I feel like out of
anybody else
had the passion in the fire right up
until he died
and just always seemed like he was
excited about his new hour
and all of that type of [__]
um
yeah but I'm not gonna lie to you I
literally felt like the guy that stayed
back three times in high school
[Music]
uh that's that's what happens that's you
know you hang around long enough here's
another one if you hang around long
enough you get to hear your generation
turn into old people which I have and
and [__] [__]
about
this is what you do when you get old you
[__] about everything that's happening
now and then you romanticize
when you grew up like the amount of
people that I see when I you know
because I'm always looking up videos
from the 80s and all of that [__]
and people are like I'm so ha I thank my
I thank my lucky stars every day that I
got to experience the 80s I just feel so
bad for the Youth today that they didn't
get to experience the 80s and it's just
like the 80s weren't that great
all right you were just young
that was the deal you were young you had
no debt you had no responsibilities no
children none of that [__] [__]
that's why the 80s were awesome for you
now while you were enjoying the 80s
there was a bunch of other people their
neighborhoods were getting taken over by
crack there was the crack 80s
um New York City had gone bankrupt the
Rust Belt was rusting out I mean it was
a bunch of horrible [__] we were in an
unbelievable economic depression but
none of that affected you
because you were like 12 13 14 and you
were watching that so all of these young
kids today who see [__] old people
from my generation [__] on them just
know that your generation is going to do
the same thing
you guys are going to be bitching when
the future being like this isn't rap I
can understand what the MC is saying
so um
that's kind of what I found so the trick
is
which I've kind of failed miserably when
it comes to sports
the trick is is to not is to maintain
that perspective and understand
that
every generation whatever decade you're
in that's their 80s or whatever the 60s
whatever 70s whatever [__] decade the
90s is another one oh weren't the 90s
the best
the [__] 90s were the best oh really
were they the best when Clinton signed
that [__] whatever the [__] he signed
that finally fully deregulated the banks
that caused the 2008 collapse which
causes us now every August to be like is
this the year our economy collapses
I oversimplified that it also you know
when you fight a [__] 20-something
year war with no [__] clear goal or
end in sight
that'll do it too right
oh look at that a blue tie in a red tie
sent us right into the [__] drink
um well what are the odds of that it's
almost like they're serving the same
Master holy [__]
so
anyway
I've been uh
so I I think the the ideal way to be an
old person is to be old steer into being
an old man you know get yourself some
sweaters some button-up sweaters
you know some sort of Bob Hope hat for
the Sun so you don't get old age spots
and get your AARP card
find a good diner
you know keep reading the newspaper
you know all that old man [__] while
simultaneously
rooting for young people
giving them advice if they ask for it
and then
just enjoying sitting back observing
like look at them right now they're in
their 80s right now do they realize it
because if you don't do that
you end up at the back of the comedy
store going like oh my God where did
everybody go
I'm old speaking of people going
somewhere the great Joe Rogan as we all
know relocated to Texas a few years ago
and guess what I I don't know if I'm
supposed to say this
he okay I don't know if this has been
released yet but um he has a certain
something that he was going to open up
out there
and he sent me a video so I'm very
excited about that
a uh
it rhymes with remedy love
I'm sure he did because somebody else
goes hey did you see that video whatever
he's opening a comedy club out there
um and it looks like it's about ready to
open
the comedy Mothership and I am very
excited for him
and uh
and stand-up comedy in general I'll tell
you wouldn't know it from my [__]
Melancholy Vibes here
is uh
I actually had the last two nights I
went down to the store I had a [__]
killer set
and I got all this new [__] that I've
been trying out and it's and it's sort
of the perfect level
of
saying something being silly making fun
of myself
and then also trashing both sides
um I'm kind of liking where it's at and
uh
which makes me excited because
I go back out on the road I'll go back
out on the road in April
um
um oh Billy's getting back in the saddle
you know after my three-month retirement
from the road which I'm only two-thirds
of the way through thoroughly thoroughly
[__] enjoyed it I'll tell you I'm
enjoying it so much I'm actually
thinking of waving at least the coffee
portion the first 10 days of the month
where I just detox I'm considering
waving the coffee thing just so I can
[__] enjoy every day this month but
I'm not going to do that
because then it's like okay I can have
some coffee and an occasional because
cigar and I'm not doing that so what I
do love is when I don't drink coffee is
the old man nap comes back
now I know it's considered an old man
nap but you're gonna you when you're in
your 20s you're going to feel the need
you're going to start feeling the need
to take a nap don't fight it
it doesn't mean you're getting old it
means you're listening to your body and
your body's saying you're tired and it's
great for your brain and evidently new
Studies have shown
one of my favorite expressions in the
English language new Studies have shown
a new study just showed that Jesus was
actually left-handed and it's like what
in the [__] information did you get
you know that somehow everybody else
missed over the last two thousand
[__] uh what's 32 minus 23 minus 32
23 7 8 9 uh over the last [__]
uh
1991 years
what the [__] information you just found
new studies show that if you take naps
and stuff like that and get eight hours
sleep and all that it's uh it's a good
way to help Stave off dementia and uh
what's the other one you get not Amnesia
dementia
and Alzheimer's
I don't know what the difference
the two is but I'm not going to Google
search that because my health insurance
will go up just by doing the search
they're just going to be like oh this
guy thinks he's forgetting things
um
so anyway
[__] else did I want to talk about
did I write anything down here I usually
have like a little set list of [__] that
I want to talk about I am really excited
that Moto GP is coming back and
it's looking like I'm gonna be going to
that race which I am [__]
Beyond excited about
um Boston Bruins still winning they're
having the greatest season in the
franchise history and I've probably seen
five games
um I am paying attention to them looking
at the box scores I saw our goalie I
don't even know his [__] name
in a 2-1 game
with Vancouver pulling the goalie
everybody in his end he gets collects
the puck
and shoots a [__] I don't know 120
foot wrista however along the [__]
Isis
to ice the game
um and Jack Edwards predictably lost his
[__] mind
um
I gotta I gotta start watching that [__]
because I want to go on the road you
know something when your team plays this
well in the regular season like when the
pla you're excited to a point and then
you kind of like
all right guys you know the playoffs are
coming you know there's like this
pressure because then everybody else
is jealous
that your team's playing so well and
they're like yeah but but what if they
don't win all of it uh then what and
then you start getting you literally
start getting like [__] like anxious
like oh [__]
what if they don't win at all like
what's gonna happen
the reality is nothing
um
but I'm trying to think of some of the
some of the teams that won
a couple of those uh Indianapolis Colts
teams in the 2000s going like [__]
15-1 13.
you know 13 and 3 14 and 2 and then
losing like back-to-back years to the
nine and seven chargers at home
um the Seattle Mariners that year they
won over 120 games
um the 1983 Boston Bruins when the
president's trophy
the first year I I went to a game and I
went to the playoffs and the first round
was best three out of five and I went to
game one of the series we played the
Canadians and we lost game one and they
[__] swept us
Pete Peters had won the Vesna trophy
I mean
that that year was such a sh
H but then you know something though we
[__] uh we would go up against those
Islander teams and they were in the
middle of their run it's not like we
were going to beat them you had to have
a team as good as the [__] Edmonton
Oilers and it took Edmonton two tries
they lost in 84 and then came back
no I'm sorry they lost in
in 83 and then came back in 84.
yeah you know what I don't think we
would have got past the Islanders even
have even having that they were just
such a [__]
machine they were a [__] machine
um but it would have been nice to not
get swept by the Canadians however
though that made finally beating them in
the playoffs way better and we've pretty
much
I don't know they they they're not a
factor anymore
is no more curse or anything and like
when we play them in the playoffs I
expect to beat them because I feel like
we usually do now which is something I
never thought I would say
now there's a bunch of french fries
there getting all [__] upset up there
in Montreal
let me uh let me let me do some of the
advertising reads here
for the week
Jesus Christ where the hell is
everything
confirm MacBook password
what is all this [__]
um all right here we go
oh look who it is everybody it's so zip
code
zip recruiter how can you break through
the Clutter and attract the most
qualified candidates for your business
you oh well let's zip
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
how does you see about it help you stand
out to the right candidates well zip
recruiters technology sends you great
candidates for your jobs and you can
send a personal invite
uh to your top choices to make an impact
sip recruiter also makes it easy for
candidates to apply to your job instead
of filling out lengthy lengthy lengthy
applications they can apply in just one
click
I don't want to fill out stuff
uh to help your job catch the eye of
great candidates they also offer
attention grabbing labels like urgent
training provided remote and more
I love the youth today
they're amazing they don't want to fill
out [__] and they don't want to go to
work
can I just stay at home and not fill out
stuff
I mean talk about a general that gets it
um get your job noticed by the best and
brightest candidates
[Music]
um going through the gears there see for
yourself go to this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com again that zip
b-u-r-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
hey man like
can I like go to work without going to
work man
I think it's great
then you can [__] stay home
then you could be like David Letterman
back in the day where he wore half a
suit and on the bottom he just had like
comfortable clothes on with sneakers
you know you could [__] do that you
can stay home you can you know be there
for your kids put down the meth I said
Put it Down hang on a second I got a
[__] Zoom meeting
no I wasn't cursing at you I was cursing
at my son
well I'd rather not get into it
no I won't turn my laptop around that's
a violation of yes I would like to still
work here but not really ever come into
the office okay here's the layout of my
house
um oh man I got into it
with my uh
I didn't want to talk about this [__]
I'm not going to talk about I went to a
[__] event and they had this covet
thing and you had to sign a release and
all of this [__] [__] because they
were filming some stuff
so I do what I always do whenever I sign
a release I just write Rich Voss I wrote
all of this [__] but these [__]
made me hold the paper up and take a
picture with it like I was going into
some sort of [__]
Work Camp
let's just say I did not handle that
well
um and you know
I had a little bit of Tourette's in that
moment
you know muttering under my breath and
all of that [__] and um
I don't know why I just said I'm not
listen I signed it I'm not taking a
picture
I should have just said that and then I
could have walked away but I didn't
I like I'll know to do that again in the
future
and you know what's funny was I walked
into the event and nobody checked to see
if you would
had gotten your covet test
um
other than that it was a well-run event
all right uh policy genius
uh if you have a family like I do you
know how much your loved ones depend on
you in a worst case scenario you
wouldn't want them to worry about money
a good life insurance plan can give you
peace of mind that if something happens
to you your family will have a safety
net to cover mortgage payments College
costs or other expenses so they can get
back on their feet and focus on what's
important already have coverage through
work no problem employers sponsored life
insurance may not offer enough
protection for your family's needs and
it won't follow you if you leave your
job now is a great time to take the lead
to Future proof your family's finances
by getting life insurance and policy
genius gives you a smarter way to find
and buy it
um uh with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies that start at
just 39 per month for two million
dollars of coverage
39 bucks
for two million dollars worth of
coverage
Jesus Christ I bet you have to be built
like Johnny Weiss Miller
now there's a reference
there is an old man reference
Johnny Weissmuller was I believe the
original guy that played Tarzan
I want to say he was an Olympic swimmer
um as some options offer coverage in as
little as a week and avoid unnecessary
medical exams policy genius has licensed
agents who can help you find the best
fit for your needs
sorry need a drink of water this [__]
the heat in my goddamn house
it's either on or it's off so it's
either drying out my goddamn throat or
I'm freezing my ass off here
um policy genius has licensed agents who
can help you find the best fit for your
needs they work for you not the
insurance companies that means they
don't have an incentive to recommend one
insurer over another unless they have a
side deal so you can trust their
guidance there's no added fees and your
personal details are private no wonder
they have thousands of five star reviews
on Google and trustpilot uh your loved
ones deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find and buy it
um head to policygenius.com or click the
link in the subscription description to
get your free life insurance quotes and
see how much you could save that's
policygenius.com
p-o-l-i-c-y-g-e-n-i-u-s.com all right
mm-hmm
and with that
let's get to the uh
let's get to the emails for this week
starting off hostile not us
I just want to say Millennials did not
come up with the water bottle flip
dumbass oh
he calls me a dumbass he doesn't even
use a period
all just all no no punctuation I just
wanted to say Millennials did not come
up with the water bottle flip dumbass it
was the generation after
all right y'all that makes sense God
knows Millennials were too afraid to
leave the house
[Laughter]
I saw this awful thing
where this [__] old broad was going
like
yeah I'm a gen xer man like if you
wonder why we're loners we do this and
did it damn we're so [__] badass it's
because we didn't have parents again it
did it's like will you shut the [__] up
why are you trying to make it us out
like we want we didn't win a war
we didn't do anything what are you
talking well maybe the Gulf War
is that really a war it was more like a
mini-series
um the first one
the Star Wars before The Empire Strikes
Back and now I think we're into the
Return of the Jedi portion of uh this
exercise over there
um
yeah
like I remember just I just started
cringing when I was watching this just
going like
like who are you making this for
for other morons in your generation that
are going to be like yeah
our music was the best our stuff was the
like what are you doing
and once again for all you young people
if you don't think that there's going to
be someone from your generation talking
about the 20s
or whatever the twizzles whatever the
[__] little [__] slangy way you're
gonna say you're [__]
um decade there's going to be somebody
doing it
I gotta find that video
I saw one as a gen xer I don't condone
this message get out of your ego you're
[__] old let young people have a good
time
so [__] bitching about them and then
exaggerating what the [__] we did okay
what did we do we had mullets and we
drank beers in the woods
okay
and we watch guys dress like women sing
about the devil that's what we were
doing all right I think it's time to
take it down a big [__] Notch all
right Valentine's Day fun fact
Hey Oh Billy boy
long time fan and podcast listener from
Germany here hey the motherland for most
of my jeans
um
just writing in to give you a fun fact
about Valentine's Day
I heard you [__] about the made up
[__] [__] holiday
where a man where a man has to celebrate
his woman and she doesn't have to do
[__]
okay well I thought you might be
delighted to know that
that that ain't the case everywhere oh
here we go in South Korea
um I'd love to go there
uh in South Korea for example it is
actually the women that are expected to
buy the guy's flowers
and especially chocolate and don't get
anything in return
that is until a month later on the 14th
of March it's called White day and then
it's the men's turn to give gifts
I wonder why it's called White day you
got to give them lilies in the end of
the day but it's all corporate [__]
anyways but hey at least this way you
know that your girl got you so you can
think twice about what you want to get
her take care of freckles love your
stuff yeah you know what's great too
which is really smart
is that they have the women celebrate
the guys first
okay because God knows if we celebrated
them first their selfish asses wouldn't
get us [__] anything so they
are basically
their incentive
is to treat you like a king so you don't
[__] them over a month later
that's fantastic
hey shout out to South Korea
hey you know what shout out to North
Korea too if you listening
um
uh I know I don't give a [__] about any
of that [__]
I I look at leaders as like independents
and then I look at the people as as
something else you know
I mean look look at what we got right
now we literally have a guy who [__]
he can't even ride a bicycle
[Laughter]
it is a lying
like such a lying sack of [__] it's like
[__] it goes into like
he like lies so much you're almost like
it's this guy
this guy has to believe these lies these
they're so [__] crazy if you've seen
that clip of him where he's like I'll
have you know I graduated the top of my
class I [__] saved a bunch of people
from a burning Bill he [__] just went
off about himself and it was all lies
and if you watch the confidence that he
delivered this [__] message
I mean unless he did some massive change
of heart because he was well until like
his 50s when he was doing that so you
kind of who you are right I don't know I
like to think I'm still changing
you know
trying to peel off another layer of the
onion remember when Madonna kept she
used to always say that justify you know
why her titties were out
whatever the [__] it was she was doing I
actually am a big fan of Madonna you
know
I like that song I Think We're Alone Now
doesn't seem to be anyone around and of
course her biggest hit oh Mickey you're
so fine you're so fine you blow my my
name Mickey
Hey Mickey
um
Borderland that was my favorite one he's
like I'm going to lose my mind the 80s
man it was the greatest decade ever
you [__] kids today
you know with your [__] youth
and your whole life said to you
you [__] [__]
I have to find that Gen X video and I
gotta [__] I gotta I gotta
do you build
at 54 do you really have to go find an
Instagram post and comment on it you
[__] loser you're right I don't I
need to get a life
one of the greatest underrated sitcoms
of all time get a life with Chris
Elliott
back in the 90s man you guys missed it
man
we went from ABC NBC CBS to Fox and WP
they added two new Networks
you have no idea what a big deal that
was all right Ohio
uh for the record I downloaded the new
yachty album
little yachty as opposed to Big yachty
Lil yachty you know he's being smart
with this money
um
I was kind of with the album until the
woman goes hey why don't you come over
and bust this [__] wide open
laughs
I would say I got to be old here what is
funny is listening to young people talk
about sex
it always reminds me of my drummer
Frank Shu shed my drum teacher right
Frank shushan the last of the great
Armenian trap drummers
he used to tell me he was in his 70s and
I was in my 20s and he was telling me
these stories of stuff he did back in
the day and my jaw was on the ground and
he just laughed and goes let me tell you
something kid every generation thinks
they're the first generation to [__]
um
which is why when I listen to like that
overtly like sexual [__] lyrics and
stuff
um
I don't know you're just sitting there
going like all right
so this is like I guess this is I guess
this was considered shocking in my
generation too we thought we were
shocking older people and I realized
that older people were listening to the
song going like yeah I've done all of
that and then some laughs
except for the religious prudes
um yeah you guys missed it man you
missed the 80s yeah you go read up on
the pmrc man
when they try to take our [__] music
away and the great D Snyder went up in
front of the [__]
I don't know what it was it was a bunch
of old guys in suits and he made a point
and then he flipped his [__] air to
let him know
Generation X was in the [__] house
you Mumble rap sons of [__] you don't
know what it was like
all right
I will tell you what was better in the
90s baseball
oh my God the [__] steroids 90s I
mean it was fire was something this I
mean you guys can have your Marvel
movies I'll take the 1998 baseball
season
[Laughter]
all right Ohio
hey Bill haven't you heard haven't heard
you mention the high the Ohio train
derailment
oh that's because I don't watch the news
I saw a little bit of that yeah there
was chemicals and stuff right the
effects have been catastrophic to the
environment
the railway needs upgrading and the
deregulary deregulation from the current
and former Administration has made it
impossible for money and attention to
fix our infrastructure problems
well that's weird because that would
create jobs that would make whoever
was in office
look good right
anyway there was a railway strike
happened a few months ago
but Grandpa Joe crushed the strike
because no one gives
a fun nationally
I think a [__] nationally about
overworked railroad workers it seemed
cliche but a hundred billion in blank
checks to fight a proxy war in the
Ukraine but they didn't bother to send
any help for cleanup to our own citizens
sir just out of curiosity are you
noticing a theme yet
when they send that money over there
to the Ukraine and all of that like the
Ukraine has to pay us back we don't just
[__] give them the money
we're getting them in debt to us and
then they have to pay us back and the
corporations get uh paid and all of that
[__] it's that confessions of an
economic Hitman [__] but if you
notice here
you know Hurricane Katrina they just let
those people [__] drown they didn't
give a [__] there was no fresh water
down in Mississippi no fresh water go
[__] yourself
uh you guys out there with your you know
dealing with chemicals
you know go [__] yourselves and [__] all
your your future health problems they
don't give a [__]
and all they do is act like you know
Democrats don't give a [__] about you
because we're Republicans and we give a
[__] about you and then Democrats go oh
no no we give a [__] about you the
Republicans don't give a [__] about you
and meanwhile neither one of them gives
a [__] about you they don't get paid
enough money it's not financially in
their best interest to give a [__] about
you it's financially in their best
interest to serve super super [__]
rich people and that's what they do all
right on both sides
so anyway the water is unsafe to drink
but officials are saying it's fine there
was a mushroom cloud of black smoke over
the wreck after they intentionally
detonated the chemicals to expediate the
clearing of the Railway to allow trains
to keep running it was a stupid and
careless decision to top it all off
there are [__] on TV saying that
because Ohio
saying that because Ohio had leaned
as you would say a cunhair towards Trump
that we deserve what was coming
please tell me nobody said that
politicizing an issue that has the
children of a town exposed to known
carcinogens is inexcusable absolutely it
is
dude out here in the valley they had a
[__] a nuclear test site that they
never cleaned it cleaned up
and to this day people are still getting
sick
they just don't we are we are all
Expendable to them
all right there would be a flame under
their ass to save let's just say it's
affecting ten thousand people if those
were the last ten thousand people in
this country they would there would be a
fire in there under their ass to save
them because they don't want to dig
their own ditches or fight their [__]
Wars that they start all right but what
this is going to affect is an Expendable
amount of people in their [__] world
that's how cold
and in human they are regardless of the
color of tie that they wear and and Fox
News in CNN doesn't give a [__] other
than blaming one side or the other for
the problem but they don't give a [__]
about you
they don't give a [__] about they all
they give a [__] about is ratings
because that's their money
so that's why I don't watch the news
that's why I don't pay attention to
politics I don't do any of that stuff
because
um
it was bad enough when I was a kid but
to now watch people
on the internet buying into it and
losing their minds and actually saying
something horrible like that well you
voted for Trump so basically you should
die of carcinogens including your
children is beyond [__] up
and equally Beyond [__] up is watching
individuals on social media become their
own version of CNN and Fox News where
they edit you know where they start
telling the story and how they're
spinning [__] to fit with their
political ideology
um
is just insane to me
um anyway
this person says with all the
environmental pushes these days it's
clear that they don't care about
not-for-profit action only when they can
tax us do they give a [__] about the
trees yeah that's true
well I'm sorry you're going through all
of that and I think once again it's
going to be up to [__] individuals
citizens to help out fellow citizens
because
[Music]
um
neither the Democrats or the Republicans
will ever help us out
and uh they work for the corporations
and corporations don't give a [__] about
us all they give a [__] about is making
more money so that would be up to us
so I don't know I'm sure there'll be
some stand-up benefit or something
or maybe I can start something figure
something out
um maybe I should [__] read up on it
I just saw it and looked devastating I
was like I don't want to look at that
which doesn't make it go away all right
this is getting gloomy all right
girlfriend dumped me after seeing
psychic listen there's got to be some
sort of GoFundMe to help people is there
a GoFundMe to actually clean it up
correctly isn't that hilarious we pay
all these taxes and then we still have
to [__] raise more money instead of
them using them
and it's so [__] brilliant to just
get people yelling at each other and
blaming different colored ties so then
nothing gets done
um girlfriend dumped me after seeing
psychic
hahaha
[Applause]
oh my God that's [__] amazing
that is [__] amazing
what a [__] awesome story
and talk about dodging a bullet
good Lord dude
if I was dating somebody and they'd
dumped me after seeing a psychic well
it'd be hard because I'd have feelings
but um standing on the outside of that
you should literally be skipping down
the street in a [__] Speedo with a
goddamn party hat on
the happiest guy
most happiest uninhibited human being in
the [__] world
Jesus Christ
do you know who was into that [__]
Adolf Hitler he was into astrology and
all of that [__] the [__] Germans for
as smart as they are
with oh with uh you know space travel
and [__] uh the automobile physics
they they they ended up being under the
control of a private that was into
[__] astrology
all right girlfriend taught me after
seeing a psychic
um hey Bill
it's all in the title yes it is my
girlfriend and her friends went to a
psychic on a bachelorette party and the
message that the spirits okay already
I'm seeing red flags
you've seen been seeing this chick for a
while you haven't popped the question
she's on a bachelorette party she's
happy for a friend and sort of low-key
jealous that's what I'm guessing the
back story is
all right throwing a bachelorette party
and the message that the spirits decided
to commune to the mystical woman working
out of a strip mall
was that I would eventually break up
with my girlfriend for another girl she
was supposedly right about a few other
things like my girlfriend's close
relationship with their grandmother and
her cats she okay so this is I was wrong
about this all right she also was aware
that my girlfriend was not married
I told her that maybe she guessed it
because my girlfriend wasn't wearing a
wedding ring she replies how does that
explain the cats
I guess I don't uh I dodged a bullet in
a way a hundred percent
it just really sucks having the fate of
your relationship decided by someone who
doesn't know either of you
I know but dude the fact that she would
listen to her that that woman's not
gonna have you back
in any situation
it's whatever somebody else what
somebody else says about you is the
truth if that's how the person you're
you're
with feels like not how you behave not
your actions not the reality of your
relationship it's the perception of
somebody else forget about some [__]
[__] doesn't even know anything about
you who's who's who's a grifter
a word a buddy of mine used the other
day I like that word
um
yeah dude you definitely dodged a bullet
anyways the person goes on to say here's
the kicker a few weeks AG later after
not talking to her and being pretty
bummed she calls me and says she might
have been wrong
I really liked her but this puts things
into perspective about her ability to
make radical decisions based on [__]
a hundred percent buddy
uh she said she might be wrong because
one of her other girlfriends was
predicted to meet her future husband on
a work trip that the next week her trip
got canceled due to weather which
negated the the psychics prediction
well she'll have the well that's because
it got canceled and it's like well how
come you didn't predict that
I'm sorry the session is over
um
anyway can't be mad at her because the
weather probably [__] it up too
wait her trip got canceled due to
weather which negated the psychus
prediction can't be mad at her because
the weather probably [__] it up too
either way I walked away from the table
with the chips I had left in my hand I
thought about what you said while making
my decision and it seemed like a layup
decision a hundred percent dude and I'm
proud of you
I'm [__] proud of you that's like
you know she doesn't have your back
or
I don't know I don't want to say this
maybe she's not the smartest person
in the world maybe she's
anywhere from gullible
to a [__] idiot which I don't know
you don't sound like a [__] idiot so
maybe she isn't but
I don't know to actually
go through with that and break up with
you
um
yeah you 100 made the right decision and
you know
I would go send that psychic flowers
and just say hey man listen I know
you're completely full of [__]
but uh
well you know something you gotta gotta
respect that psychic that you predicted
something so negative
um
usually they say positive [__] don't
they well I guess they got to throw some
negatives in there to make it seem like
they're telling the truth
hey any uh any guilt-ridden psychics out
there wanna [__] uh
confess anything on this podcast
let me let me let me do this is the last
thing
psychic
comes clean
no internet
oh the psychics are there all over me
here
all right well you guys that that's your
homework you guys Google that and then
send me some articles has there ever
been you know because there's been
magicians that have actually you know
broken the Code of Silence
and told how they put the [__] they
got the rabbit in the Hat or whatnot
uh maybe there's some psychics out there
to be like all right this is how uh I'm
not saying we all do it this way
but this is how I used to [__]
people don't you feel like the longer
you live that you can kind of like
you can what the [__] is that on
you can kind of um
you get those Hannibal lecture skills
you know what I mean
you look at like a like how a woman's
dressed or something like that
and you know you start you can tell you
know things about her right you look at
how a guy you know and women want to be
like yeah
ladies you're not that deep
you're not that deep all right
um
and then guys I mean Jesus Christ
speaking of not that deep
um
yeah I saw a guy walking across the
street the other day and I could tell he
had a bad relationship with his father
and he had gotten into a lot of fights
and that he was kind of on the other
side of that and he was trying to settle
down
and not be that guy and all he did was
walk in front of my car
all right I'm not saying I'm right on
any of that
but I could [__] sit there and have a
veil
and a little head wrap on and I I could
[__] do some [__]
I can grow some facial hair
you need weird facial hair right
like that guy back in the day that was
into Satan
in the 1960s remember that [__] weird
Lucifer guy and these celebrities would
hang out with him
which by the way
it's one of the things I learned a long
time ago in the uninformed the late
great uninformed show
was that satanists don't believe in
Satan
they don't believe in a devil a heaven
or hell or anything like that they just
what they believe in is just living for
yourself
so you just
do things that you want to do that makes
you feel good
you know bang whoever you want to bang
do drugs
[__] not do that [__] if that makes
you feel good don't have kids because
they take up too much of your time
that's what it is it's not like they're
sitting there you know sacrificing uh
whatever the [__] you sack what do you
sacrifice
in a Satanic ritual is it a goat is it a
virgin
I have no idea anyway that's the podcast
everybody
MotoGP is coming up next month as is
Formula One
racing season starts baseball season
starts March Madness
NHL and NBA playoffs
are right around the corner and if that
isn't exciting enough
all freckles
Oh Billy red face
Oh Billy [__] dropping pounds over
here
[__] eating protein and [__]
greens baby
I'm coming back out on the road I'm
starting off with a gig in Ottawa
and then I go to New York City to do the
10th Annual Patrice O'Neal Comedy
benefit at the New York City Center we
just added a surprise guest
meaning somebody famous is going to come
down there and do 15 minutes for you
very excited about that
um
I stayed out a little bit late but other
than that I feel pretty rested
I like where my ACT is and I think I'm
going to do this more often I think once
a year
I'm going to take three months off on
the road while still working on my ACT
still pitching shows still doing acting
stuff but I just won't be traveling
I can do that right
I mean if you guys can fill out an
application with one click and work
remotely why can't I take a couple
months off from the road
while keeping my ACT sharp down at The
Comedy Store
built Bill no one's saying you can't do
that
I got to get a [__]
a humidifier is what the [__] I gotta
get
um
every morning I wake up with a [__]
scratchy throat over here anyways that's
the podcast go [__] yourselves and I
will uh I'll check in on you on Thursday